- Good morning believe nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe
and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is create
something different.
Over to you Shigeru Miyamoto.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
♫ I wake up every morning ♫
So as entrepreneurs, we like
to create different things.
It's part of what we do.
We don't like working for the may,
we don't want a typical corporate job,
we want to create our own thing.
We want to self express
and we want to make something different.
I think that's something
that should speak to you
as an entrepreneur if you're
watching this channel.
I feel like I'm already
speaking to the converted
and I don't need to express the importance
of making something different.
That's what we do as
entrepreneurs, that's our role.
Here's a challenge that I think that
makes it difficult for entrepreneurs.
We don't continue enough
to make different things.
Entrepreneurs are really good at the start
of coming up with some bold brand new idea
and then launching it.
Now whether it becomes successful or not,
tweaking, tweaking, tweaking,
trial and error, testing,
customer feedback 'til you hit something.
What ends up happening next though
is what screws over a
lot of entrepreneurs,
they stop creating something different.
Because they found this thing
that they think is a recipe for success,
they found the one way to do
something that was different
and they're doing it over
and over and over again
and it's generating cash for them
then they stop evolving.
And that's the death
toll for an entrepreneur.
If you are not continuing to evolve,
to create new things, to be different,
then you're going to get
bored of your business
and this happens to so many entrepreneurs.
I can't tell you how many
entrepreneurs I talked to
that are three, four, five
years into the company and say,
"I'm bored, I'm looking
for something different.
"I don't know, maybe
I'll sell my business."
Or they start on some
like passion project,
some side thing that they
want to get going and doing.
And here's what happened.
They had so much creative
energy, and so much difference
going into the first part of
their business in the beginning
and then they found the thing that worked
and so they stuck with that
and they stop evolving.
They evolved as a human.
We constantly evolve, we
constantly get new interests,
we constantly want to try new things.
They evolved and grew,
but they didn't grow
their business with them.
Your business should
constantly be a reflection
of who you are and what
you're interested in doing.
If you are sticking down a business line
that you are not passionate about anymore,
then you're never going
to have huge success.
If that's you, if you are not passionate
all about your business,
then chances are, you grew too
far away from your business.
You grew and your business stayed here.
And even though it's making money,
it's not interesting to you anymore.
And so if that's you, sell it
and go find something else.
Don't find some side hobby passion thing.
Get out of your entire business
and go try something else.
And for the next one,
and if you guys aren't at that
point yet in your business,
where you get bored of it
or you're just on the cusp,
evolve your company with you.
So if you look at my
business, it started off
me doing seminars.
I was invited to speak, I sold my company
when I was 22 years old, how old am I now?
37.
So it's 15 years doing this.
It's easy to get bored.
Now I still love helping entrepreneurs.
That is still a huge passion of mine.
But the execution of it changes.
It started off me just doing
speaking, and I love that.
And then it evolved to
me doing my website,
and I love that.
And that evolved from me
focusing on my website
to spending a lot more time
on Youtube, and I love this.
And this may evolve to something else.
I'm not sold on being a Youtuber
for the rest of my life.
Something will change, I'll shift
and I'll go off and do something else.
It'll still be likely around
helping entrepreneurs,
that's my passion.
But how to do it will
shift, will evolve and grow.
My introductions on these
channels are changing.
The video series that I try.
So it's like there's the macro changes
of the projects I take on,
from speaking to website to Youtube.
And then there's a micro evolution inside.
From launching a new series,
and testing and seeing
and always trying new things to see
how it can improve and make it better.
If I stop doing those
things, I would start to die.
And then I'd have to get out of it.
So stop dying in your business.
Continue, constantly,
to introduce new things,
to get this thing excited and invigorated
so you never get bored with your business.
So the question today is I'm curious,
have you ever been bored in your company
and what did you do to change it?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to C.X. Koehler,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book.
I understand it was as a gift actually.
So I hope you enjoy the gift
and you're reading it and
applying it to your life
and your business.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going ♫
- The Lion King was of
course, it was huge.
Especially 'cause I did it
for all the wrong reasons.
I mean I did it for my daughter because
I wanted to show off as dad.
And I was doing all these grown up movies
where people were getting killed
and I couldn't take her to a premier.
I wanted to do something to
take my kid to a premier.
And it was surprisingly
emotional doing that movie.
It deals with a father's death.
It's got a lot more depth
than the surface that we believe.
And it shocked me, my own response.
You know once I started writing on it,
because I was thinking, oh
this is going to be easy.
And it wasn't like it was hard.
But the emotional involvements
only became profound
as supposed to hard.
And really with Lion King,
that got Terry Malick
interested in me for instance.
Terry loved Lion King and
wanted me to do Thin Man Lines.
So all these things,
working with Ridley Scott.
I mean we've done some
really good movies together.
And they're stylistically so different.
I mean Black Rain is so
different from Thelma and Louise.
It's so different from Gladiators,
it's so different from Hannibal,
it's so different from Black Hunt Down.
It's so different from Match stick men.
I'm sure I'm leaving some out.
So working with people who, like me,
they get a little bored
doing the same thing
and off they go trying to do
something completely different.
I mean that's the big part of it.
- Reality television shows is so big now.
I like to get on the bandwagon,
whenever I can find one.
And I felt if we're going to do a cartoon
an animated movie for the Hub Network,
I want to make it more
different than anything before.
Why not make it a
reality animated cartoon.
So in order to make it a reality cartoon,
we have real people in it.
I'm as real as I know I can get.
So I'm in it, we have a
few other real people in.
- [Larry King] You got
Jim Belushi isn't it?
- Jim Belushi.
- [Larry King] Christian Slater?
- They're doing the voices.
- Teri Hatcher, Sean Astin,
Armie Hammer is in it.
Flee and Darren Chris, they're
all voicing superheroes.
Are the superheroes new heroes?
- They're all new heroes.
Actually they're aliens
from another planet.
Which is not unusual in a superhero story.
- Let me tell you, in order
to have something different,
you are going to have to
do something different.
In order to have something more,
you have to do something
you haven't done yet.
I had to say the things
I didn't want to say,
do the things I didn't feel like doing
to have the life I knew I wanted, period.
Period.
And all I did was give instructions.
Here, do this bit size, do this
bite size, do this bite size
bite size, digestible, palatable
pieces of what you can do.
Does that sound good you guys?
And when you look up,
and you don't have to
have a magnificent change
over 12 months, have a
small change over 30 days.
And a small change over 30 days.
Your break through will
come in needle point moves.
And you'll look up in five years,
and not recognize your life.